in competitive games that feature them
ultimate abilities are part of what
makes a character powerful and unique
now the best alts are meta defining but
some are just so cool they deserve
recognition anyway for our list of the
top 10 ultimate abilities we looked at
how strong an alt is how impactful it
was in its original game and yes how
iconic it is for this list we considered
overwatch League of Legends dota 2
heroes of the storm and fighting games
now without further ado let's get into
it with the top 10 ultimate abilities
starting things off at number 10 is one
of League of Legends most recognizable
Ultimates Zed's and death mark death
mark lets Zed go crazy diving at his
opponent and dealing a ton of damage in
just a few seconds before disappearing
back into the shadows and it's part of
what makes him such a popular soloqueue
champion
wait didn't usable holy mine well it
gives players the ability to outplay
their opponents this ultimate has carved
out its place in League of Legends
history thanks to a talented mid laner
from Korea that you might have heard of
you are looking for an alt that enables
your team to do just about whatever they
want then look no further than number 9
on our list za Ria's graviton surge the
third
they absolutely wrecked us a graviton
sucks in every nearby opponent into one
spot on the map opening them up for
dragon strike dragon blade high noon
earth chatter self-destruct or any other
damage friendly alt that your team has
at their disposal but now what the
program drops on over the top from the
floor perhaps people in the ceiling and
on the top it's raining down below leap
with the quad kill and make no mistake a
perfect graviton could turn the tide for
you and your comrades
[Music]
three people dropped into the pit by
that graviton oh my goodness
rocking the number eight spot is et C's
mosh pit from heroes of the storm like
graviton this is a huge crowd control
ability but unlike graviton it's CeCe's
your enemy with the power of a rock and
roll Saul's malthael looking for the
ring you will ever see the horrify goes
up ET seasick guitar solo forces nearby
enemies to dance making them prime
targets for your damage dealers
combined with his powerslide ability a
good etc' player should be making his
opponents rock out so his allies can
provide the knockout punch coming in at
number seven is one half of DotA's
iconic the play tide hunters ravage
[Music]
demand crowd control abilities are
always going to be powerful but ravage
might just be the coolest looking of the
bunch
since you're literally calling on the
tentacles of an abyssal god to stun and
damage your enemies moving into the
midst of it all hate does get the ravage
out in time beautiful sunny cold 5-foot
sample and steady of the secret of every
wrestler kiss the pogo strike and the
big heavy L is able to take down a there
are very few spells in DotA that feel
worse than falling victim to a five-man
ravage but then again there is the other
half of the plays devastating combo
[Applause]
fighting games originated the concept of
an ultimate ability with supers and
while good super is strong a great super
should be meta defining so it shouldn't
come as a surprise that Street Fighter 3
third strike Ken's Shifu Jean Ricci aku
comes in at number 6 on our list since
it combos out of just about any punch or
kick that Ken likes to throw
it also punishes plenty of supposedly
safe attacks and is fully invincible and
starts up so fast that if your opponent
blocks it you can sometimes beat their
punished with another Shippo
[Music]
it also gives Ken plenty of super meter
to play with for when he doesn't need to
unload a flurry of kicks right in your
face no ken player worth their salt
picks anything else which means the game
revolves around Ken and his tornado
kicks
[Applause]
breaking the seal on the top half of our
list is faceless voids chronosphere
which if we're being honest is one of
these strongest crowd control abilities
in any MOBA
every $10
Cronos fear locks down every player
caught in its bubble teammates enemies
everyone but void that means teamwork is
key to making the most of a five man
chrono actually just and the Bulldog
doesn't have the refresher his ship to
use it now there's a spirit by once
again another and like all great alts it
defines the meta if you know your
opponent has chrono up you're going to
avoid getting grouped up for fear of
getting bubbled up and then popped so
he's gonna turn this always
he needs more help it shouldn't be
shocking to see orianna's shockwave take
number four on our list just like Kronos
for your teams are forced to play around
the terrifying CC shockwave provides but
unlike the dota 2 ultimate enemy players
are rarely safe from orianna's ball
thanks to her incredible range as shown
off by faker the leading kt rolster back
in 2017 trying to get out with his life
but it just doesn't look very likely and
good god off the back side of the
paradise gate deep blow the game wide
open but every good shock wave is a team
effort communication is key to making
the most of dragging all your enemies to
one spot for just a moment so your
allies can erase them with damage of
their own try to get to the backline II
did get hit by emo play expect it's okay
Big O
Oh
[Applause]
sometimes it's all about what you don't
see Akuma's raging demon takes number
three on our list
thanks to just how iconic it is
raging demon may not be the strongest
finishing move in Street Fighter history
but there's nothing cooler than watching
Akuma - to an opponent and Maul them in
the shadows you were left to imagine
just how badly Akuma is beating into
them and when it ends all you see is
their body lying on the ground with a
kuma posing over them it's also provided
some of competitive street fighters
coolest moments including infiltration
dominating his opponents at evo 2012
with some of the clutch's fastest raging
demons ever taking a page from japan's -
Kido
and toki doping off at evo 2017 with an
IRL demon of his own you can see the
first
Labor's the pose on the evolution saves
your champions whole Quito and Street
Fighter 5 heroes never died
the only reason Mercy's resurrect isn't
number one on this list is because it's
early iteration was so strong that
Blizzard had to nerf it down to a
regular ability
before it was nerfed res was perhaps the
most meta defining ultimate of all time
and was so strong it essentially put
other support characters out of the job
to connect on to these shots that his
team is so desperately needed but
there's a revive coming out of it
they're a fantastic rebirth getting
quite a few people back alive and a sob
rare to follow up with sure healing is
nice but there's nothing more powerful
than bringing multiple allies back to
life after your opponent's wasted health
and cooldowns trying to kill them it's a
bit of a surprise but crucial pick for
runaway dancerettes are gonna breached
it back up again but worth it saving
that one
and even though Mercy's new res only
targets one ally it's still invaluable
in fights seems like a good ultimate
never dies either a little bit strangely
on the outside of the bubble HGC try to
stay alive through all this damage he
has a harmony off and the mercy heal is
keeping him on his feet this is
incredible to the Jornet spirits by
Canada
taking first place is the strongest
ultimate we can think of enigmas black
hole from dota 2 black hole like its
crowd control cousins defines the pace
of a teamfight how your enemy's position
themselves around you and can decide
entire games
unlike chronosphere though the perfect
black hole doesn't necessarily require
teamwork instead hitting a clean black
hole is all about individual skill
positioning timing foresight every key
team fighting skilled ona tests you on
is on display in a good black hole
it's about to fall
and since it doesn't affect your
teammates the soloqueue randos can't
even mess it up
now they gotta bring up don't let it get
away let me get this killed well guys
that's our list now it's time to use
your youtuber ultimate ability which is
commenting on this video
and telling us all the things we got
wrong thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button